welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with summer
finally upon us what better way to
celebrate with one of the most
disturbing horror movies of all time
midsummer is now out for worldwide
release and throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the film and its
ending if you've been following the
channel closely then you'll know that
last month I did a full breakdown of the
movie script and in this video I'll also
be recapping some of the insights that
it offers about the film and its
characters this is full spoilers ahead
so if you haven't seen the movie yet and
don't want anything ruined then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for quick in this video now sit back
relax and let's get into my breakdown of
midsummer I'm just gonna call it
midsummer throughout this entire review
I know some people are calling a
midsummer but Ari aster did say that so
I'm sticking by what he said anyway at
its core midsummer is a film about the
breakdown of a toxic relationship that
just so happens to be set against
terrifying circumstances we follow Danny
played expertly by Florence Pugh who
after the loss of her family due to a
heartbreaking tragedy finds herself
alone with no one to turn to other than
her boyfriend Christian Christian was
planning on breaking up with Danny
however due to the girl that he feels
over her loss and the eventual guilt of
isolation that she puts on him he
postpones it and invites her on a trip
to house England a Swedish festival that
only happens once every 90 years
Danny throughout the film goes on an arc
that is pretty much caused by the loss
of her family and throughout the movie
she drifts from group to group
desperately seeking acceptance no matter
the cost to those around her
one thing that you have to understand
about the character and her motives is
that she is deep down a person that
because of the heavy loss in her life
clings to any attention that comes
towards her no matter how negative it
may be she is just as guilty as
Christian is for committing to their
relationship when both know that it is
simply not working and it's also ads way
to why the film ends the
that it does anyway as the group arrived
at housing land they discover a place
that like Danny and Christians
relationship seems picture-perfect on
the surface but it's hiding a lot of
Secrets beneath it the ha gasps whoo
Danny eventually ends up turning to you
come across as kind and welcoming people
but deep down similar to Christian that
they have their own agenda in this
script ha gasps are basically the
product of generations of incest and
hanging ball carcasses from branches and
look like 19th century farmers that
spend most of their time dancing around
the Maypole though they seem like a
group of hippies that hang out magic
mushrooms like it's nothing eventually
their way of life and the rituals that
they begin to carry out make it clear
that things on right they far outnumber
the group and this makes them
intimidating as they slowly start to
pick everyone apart the hog ass as
they're known communicate through little
gestures and expressions known as
effects which hint have their true
intentions without notifying others and
early on these slight language barriers
highlight that this is all an act for
them every time one Hagen is born the
group planted tree that has apparently
tie directly to their life and as it
grows they do to their affection for
earth place into the foam later and they
almost live their life purely based off
nature alone the whole gas view their
lives as seasons with spring being their
childhood and summer their young
adulthood in which they go out on a
pilgrimage they then return up to 32 to
be an elder of the camp for autumn and
in their winter years at the age of 72
they commit suicide by jumping off a
cliff which is one of the film's most
shocking moments there's a strong theme
of pregnancy lace throughout the film as
well as force death which is similar to
how Danny found herself in such tragic
situations through the loss of her
family and during the film neces message
of out with the old and in with the new
which itself can be viewed as the ending
of one relationship in order to take on
another Danny at some points even
struggles with this detachment and
though she wants to leave hälsingland
at several points is enabled to do to
one circumstance or another which is of
course eerily similar to how she refuses
to leave her relationship with Christian
even though it's definitely for the best
that she does she's reminded by
instances such as Simon and Connie that
leaving your comfort zone can often have
dire consequences and metaphorically
them attempting to leave the camp only
to die showcase
is why she is hesitant to break things
off with Christian it's only when she
sees first hand due to Christian
sleeping with one of the local girls
things simply unkown to work out I as
I'm sure many of you watching have been
in similar circumstances relationship
wise where though we may have not been
cheated on we still were unable to
accept just how bad things really were
until they were staring us in the face
Danny has to deal with this and it's
pretty much the last straw excuse the
pun for her to break things off and look
for something else we all wear masks
when it comes to dealing with others and
the dichotomy of Christians true
feelings juxtaposed with the way that he
acts towards Danny showed that you
allottee in his motives there's always
something going on beneath the surface
and this is further exemplified by the
duality of the festival and most notably
when Alf where's Mark skin at layer in
the movie Danny herself is made to dance
around the Maypole and similar to her
relationship seems happy though there is
subtext lace rather she is breaking
inside because she's just so exhausted
by the continual circle that she's going
into both literally during the dance and
figuratively in her life with Christian
neither are willing to break it off till
after this moment when Danny wins which
shows that she has finally broken the
circle of the toxic relationship in the
end she's pronounced the queen
but unlike game of thrones that this
Danny sticks around after being paraded
through the field kissed and adorned
with flowers she's finally ready to cut
off the negative aspects of their life
and join her new family symbolically the
burning of Christian and his friends in
the final sacrifice shell that she is
letting go of all the things that have
held her back and is ready to move on
but the finale we watch is christian
melts into the fire and Danny is paraded
as the new Queen she goes through a mix
of emotions including excitement fear
confusion but ultimately she's happy
happy that she finally has a new family
and is accepted the character has gone
insane but in her mind she is a queen
worshipped by all and finally living a
life free of paranoia and distrust which
ends the film whilst this could be taken
as a happy ending for the character
sadly she is once again in a situation
that seems like it's the best thing for
her but will ultimately end up pushing
her further
the deep end her desperation to gain
affection without questioning whether
it's really worth it
has placed her into a situation of
dependency once more that will not
strengthen her beyond how she was with
Cristian as Danny has not learned to be
strong around and is still reliant on
others for happiness she will therefore
not build a foundation within herself in
which she can live without approval from
outside sources it's a brilliant tragic
end that serves as a warning that if
you're going to jump from relationship
to relationship without working on
yourself first then you always bound to
repeat the things that have ultimately
led to your downfall oh it's just
another Wickham and ripoff that has no
value you decide but I think most of us
know there's a lot more to it than some
of the critics are ultimately giving it
credit for so what did I think of the
film well as I'm sure you can guess this
again is another masterpiece by Ari
Astor that once more cements the
director is one of the best voices in
horror that we currently have this shows
that things like the conjuring universe
which in my opinion have dumbed down
horror a bit aren't to be taken as this
decades example of the genre and now I
don't think that this top torretta Terry
it's still horrifying Midsomer is
haunting from beginning to end and it's
use of vibrancy and over-the-top colors
is what makes it so unnerving Midsomer
is as spellbinding as it is horrific and
some of the gore really stands out here
purely due to just how picturesque
everything in the movie seems there's
very little to fault about the film and
whilst it's got a pretty long runtime
it's still outstanding to behold I can
see lots of people wanting to book trips
to the Maypole festivals next year
purely of this film alone and it's a
really unique take on a genre that has
become pretty comfortable with just
piling movies with lazy jump scares and
moronic characters when reading the
script before I ever saw the film I was
really curious to see how this would
play out on-screen and it doesn't
disappoint midsummer goes beneath the
surface of human emotion and delivers a
wholly satisfying Scarefest that will
stay with you long after you leave the
theater and that's why it gets a 9 out
of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie and what you took from its
ending if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
week's other big release spider-man far
from home which you'll be linked at the
end I'll also leave a link to my
original script breakdown for the film
so if you want a more in-depth look at
how the story was created then make sure
that you give it a watch after this and
leave both linked at the end so it's
entirely up to you what one you want to
choose but I'll see you over at those
videos Cheers
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]